very happy to be here with Klaus the
first time I've met the new head of
Porsche America's thank you so much for
joining us and in front of this amazing
car people who aren't gearheads won't
understand the significance of this the
most powerful naturally aspirated engine
that Porsche makes in a 911 with a stick
shift can you please make more
unfortunately we can't because we sold
that car and it was instantly sold out
it's limited to 991 units and I think we
would not be made in favor of those
people who forwardly purchase thing but
people love the fact that it's got the
stick shift for all the technologically
innovative products that you build and
God love the PDK it's an amazing system
shifts are instantaneous and super crisp
people still like the old-school stick
shift people still like the actual feel
of operating the machine do you feel
like you're gonna build more products in
this direction oh well it was such a
strong statement of you we will
certainly look into the manual gear gear
box in the future as well and I'm I'm
being serious this is really something
especially in America is really
important and we're going to take out so
the save the manuals campaign has worked
well with Porsche owes you guys have
done so well with the cayenne and now
with the makan do you see more
developments in that direction I always
want to hear about new products and it
seems like there's there's so so far to
go well more development we just brought
the 4-cylinder makan here now lots of
people are saying 4-cylinder porsche SUV
but you know zero to 60 in 6.1 seconds
shows that that car has got a lot of
potential in terms of performance and
then if we go a few years from now at
the end of the decade we're going to
bring a battery electric vehicle that's
the big new thing for Porsche that so
the battery electric to zero emissions
vehicle is a big new thing but hybrids
have always been really a focus for you
when are we going to see that with the
911 with the flagship well there's no
clear date on it we're just saying that
the 911 also has got potential for a
hybrid technology look at the 918 Spyder
that has shown that there's a lot of to
the electric and
combining that with a combustion engine
in terms of performance and the sold-out
also sold out I'm sorry about that yeah
I can't get any of those cars well
building more I promise what about on
the lower end of the range I mean
Porsches a brand that is out of grasp
for so many who so many young and
deserving fans are you planning on
building more affordable cars for those
people well actually define affordable
now the makan four-cylinder is out and
about for 47,500 US dollar it won't get
very much lower than that I'm thinking
about more of a 914 kind of a retro 914
rebirth now we never talk about the
future you know and actually saying
we're bringing that or not bringing that
we're always looking into potentials but
at the moment i can't say anything about
a new 94 you can tell me when we're off
camera let's talk about sales growth at
porsche you hit record after record but
the industry also has been growing at
such a fast pace do you see that kind of
slowing down this year or next year well
everybody's talking about the tipping
point here in the US that's for sure and
I think after five years of our constant
growth in terms of Porsche it's a ten
percent and more growth every year since
five years everybody is expecting to
slow down with that do we expect it I
think we can still make a growth story
this year I think we can still exceed
our previous year sales but it is
slowing down ever so slightly let me ask
about what you do then I mean beyond
just growing unit sales Porsches
building a deeper and deeper connection
with customers how's that working out
for the company i know a lot of our
viewers a lot of wall street employees
are driving Porsches and going to racing
schools and participate participating in
programs do you see that as a bigger
revenue stream in the future certainly i
mean here in the united states with two
Porsche experience centers where we have
our own track our own facilities one in
Atlanta one that we are just about to
finish in Los Angeles on the west coast
and we are going to let people in in
terms of California it's going to be
50,000 people per year that we expect to
come there take their car out and ride
it to the limit but in a very safe
environment
so we are seeing a revenue stream from
that and this is actually you can take
your car to where it belongs to actually
off the public roads into an enclosed
environment where you can test out the
limits of that car